sergeant bowe bergdahl goes free in
breaking news Plus Hillary Clinton
basically just gave up the Democratic
Party to Bernie Sanders and we'll check
the mailbag i'm ben shapiro this is the
ben shapiro show all righty so breaking
news sergeant bowe bergdahl the guy who
just pled guilty to both desertion and
misbehavior before the enemy and could
have received life in prison instead
goes free he receives zero prison time
I'll explain just how a rageous this is
plus some comments from the judge that
are nearly as outrageous in just a
second first I want to say thank you to
our sponsors over at Birch gold so right
now the economy seems to be doing really
well there's a new economic report out
today shows unemployment is down to 4.1
percent stock market continues to rise
but the question is going to be what
happens when the bubble bursts because
the bubble inevitably borås every 8 10
years there's some sort of economic
crisis in the United States
the last one was in 2007 so it's been
just a little while that means that you
should at least be hedging your bets a
little bit
I'm not saying take all your money out
of the stock market I'm not saying don't
invest in real estate I am saying take
some of your money and put it in
precious metals as a hedge against
inflation and again stock market busts
and that is why I trust the folks over
at Birch school to do just that right
now thanks to a little on the IRS tax
law you can move your IRA or eligible
401k into an IRA backed by physical gold
or silver or you can just invest in
precious metals by calling up my friends
at Birch gold birchgold.com / Ben that's
birchgold.com / Ben they have a
long-standing track record of continued
success but thousands of satisfied
clients
countless five-star reviews an A+ rating
with the Better Business Bureau contact
them ask all your questions make sure
you feel secure and then invest some of
your money in precious metals that give
you a comprehensive 16 page kit
revealing how gold and silver can
protect your savings and again how you
can legally move your IRA or 401k out of
stocks and bonds and into a precious
metals IRA birchgold.com / Ben
birchgold.com / Ben make sure that
you're diversified birchgold.com
/ Ben okay so the breaking news is that
bob bergdahl sergeant bowe bergdahl who
as you recall was treated as a hero by
the Obama administration was actually a
traitor or at the very least a deserter
he deserted his post while he was in
Afghanistan his fellow his fellow
soldiers some of whom I know and have
met some of them have told me that he
was a weirdo before that he wandered off
wander directly into the hands of the
Taliban he says he goes in trying to
join the Taliban whatever he was trying
to do they ended up basically capturing
him and keeping him in captivity for
several years President Obama then
traded five Gitmo terrorists in favor of
Bowe Bergdahl so he got wandered off his
post not only did he do that we had to
send out soldiers looking for him
because it seemed like he might have
been captured right not that he would
deserter but that he might have been
captured and six American soldiers were
killed in the process of attempting to
of attempting to get the guy back plus a
military dog as well that's according to
Mark Thompson over at Time magazine in
2014 he wrote then chances are you
haven't heard of the six soldiers who
died hunting for Bergdahl after he went
missing according to military officials
now that Bergdahl has been sprung
soldiers who served with Bergdahl
grumbling that he deserted and shouldn't
be hailed as a hero especially given the
resulting cost in American lives
Bergdahl himself pled guilty to
desertion and misbehavior in the face of
the enemy according to Politico today of
The Associated Press a military judge
has found that Bowe Bergdahl should
serve no prison time zero prison time
for endangering his comrades by walking
off his Afghanistan post the judge also
gave Bergdahl a dishonorable discharge
reduced his rank to private said he must
forfeit pay equal to one thousand
dollars per month for ten months a ten
thousand dollar fine for getting six
American soldiers killed because he
walked off duty really a desertion needs
to be punishable by tree I used to be
treated like treason right wife and
prisoner you're taking in front of a
firing squad you get your fellow
soldiers killed because you decide to
wander off your post and join the
Taliban or at least go and hang out with
them and you don't get any prison time
at all they just bust you down to
private and take away some money
according to Politico prosecutors that
starts if punishments because of wounds
to service members who searched for
Bergdahl after he disappeared in 2009
some of those wounds are really Grievous
there's guy in a wheelchair because the
Bergdahl the defense sought to counter
that evidence with testimony about
Bergdahl suffering during his five years
as a captive Taliban allies his
contributions to military intelligence
and survival instruction and his mental
health problems Bergdahl was 23 years
old when after five months in
Afghanistan he disappeared from his
remote infantry post near the Pakistan
border triggering a massive search
operation and then he showed up in the
hands of the Taliban and of course in
May 2014 he was handed over to US
Special Forces in a swap with the
Taliban here's what's most outrageous
about this
it's most outrageous about those pointed
out by John pod over a commentary
magazine this is just a few days ago the
New York Times reported quote the judge
in this case again named Colonel Jeffrey
Nance said quote I will consider the
president's comments as mitigation when
mitigation evidence as I arrived in an
appropriate sentence ok mitigation
evidence I mean that's insane so
basically what the defense was trying to
say is they were trying to say that
Trump was making statements about the
case and they talked about how Trump had
had made numerous statements during the
nomination and in the general election
about bowe bergdahl and the accused then
pled guilty and then he held a press
conference on October 16th 2017 and he
said I can't comment on Bowe Bergdahl
because I guess he's doing something
today but they're sending up sentencing
so I'm not going to comment on him but I
think people have heard my comments in
the past the defense immediately filed
for dismissal saying that Trump had
biased the case beyond measure and
therefore they should release Bergdahl
the judge that I'm not gonna release
Bergdahl based on that but I will be
taking this into account right he said
that he would take into account as
mitigation evidence what Trump had said
and pretty pretty ridiculous so they
they said that essentially he says at
the end of his little ruling he said I
will consider the president's comments
as mitigation evidence as I arrived in
appropriate sentence in this case
furthermore I will require anyone
involved in any way in the exercise
exercise of discretion in any post trial
aspect of this case to read the
statement from the White House press
office of 20 October 2017 before they
exercise that discretion unless the
defense requests that not issue that
order because on October 20th there have
been some statement from the White House
about all of this it was a statement
regarding military justice and instead
quote the president quote expects all
military personnel who are involved in
any way in the military justice process
to exercise their independent
professional judgment right and so the
judge said he wasn't going to take this
into account but he did take it into
account it looks a lot like the judge
basically said I'm not gonna release
Bergdahl because Trump did this but I'll
kind of release Bergdahl because Trump
did this at least that's that seems to
be the implication here pretty
horrifying stuff
Bergdahl no doubt will be treated as a
hero by the left in exactly the same way
that Chelsea Manning has been treated as
a hero by the left anyone who turns
against the US military is treated at
least by a segment
to the hole left by by a segment of the
more extreme left as somebody who has
done something worth celebrating and
bowe bergdahl I'm sure get a large
contract from some book company in order
to tell his story well the people who
were shot and wounded or killed
searching for him ends up you know with
nothing just just insane disgusting
stuff okay well meanwhile the Democrats
are in complete disarray one thing that
is very clear is that Bernie Sanders now
runs the Democratic Party Bernie Sanders
is the king of the Democratic Party he
lost the battle but he won the war he
lost in 2016 but he won the war because
now every Democrat goes on bended knee
to pay homage to to Bernie Sanders all
of his agenda items must be must be
treated with respect when he talks about
Medicare for all you have people like
Elizabeth Warren and people like Cory
Booker and people like Kamala Harris all
paying homage to to Bernie Sanders
priorities it's amazing how a loon bag
old socialist who's never passed a
serious piece of legislation in his life
was kicked out of a communist Evan TS
for being too useless for a commune
right that guy is now the leader of the
Democratic Party yeah it's no more
absurd certainly than Donald Trump being
the leader of the Republican Party but
it does demonstrate the loss of faith in
the parties themselves have led to the
takeover of those parties by outside
forces Sanders is an outside force Trump
is an outside force and this
demonstrates again that when you have
parties that have lost their way when
you have parties that don't have a
reason for existence they are
susceptible to being taken over it's
it's really obvious now that folks like
Elizabeth Warren are crowning Bernie
Sanders King and the only question is
what Bernie Sanders is gonna do with
that so here's Elizabeth Warren was
asked yesterday by Jake Tapper on CNN
whether Bernie was robbed in the 2016
election cycle by Hillary Clinton in the
DNC she had said you're the she said
last year that he was not robbed but now
she's switched her tune because
obviously everyone must now must now
bend before Bernie this is a test for
Tom Perez and either he's gonna
see by bringing burgers and Bernie
Sanders representatives into this
process and they're going to say it's
fair it works we all believe it or he's
going to fail and I very much hope he
succeeds I hope for Democrats everywhere
I hope for Bernie and for all Bernie
supporters they're gonna succeed very
quickly senator do you agree with the
notion that it was rigged yes okay so
suddenly she had ruses the notion that
it was rigged funny how that works right
five seconds ago five seconds ago she
was saying it wasn't rigged now she's
saying it's rigged does that sound
honest to you or is that sound like
playing political games does that sound
like she knows that Bernie Sanders is
the power inside the party this loon bag
old sceptic septuagenarian Socialist
from Vermont that guy the guy who who
you can find recordings out singing this
land is your land this land is my land
and his crazy voice really it's worth
it's worth watching we'll have to pull
out at some point that guy now runs the
Democratic Party so the question becomes
this is Bernie Sanders is Bernie Sanders
going to actually run for president
again in 2020 I think he would be a fool
not to I think that if he ran in 2020
he'd win the nomination and he would
likely win the presidency truly I think
that is that is a very high possibility
now he also has the possibility he could
sit outside and just become the patrons
of the Democratic Party he could sit
outside he could campaign for all the
candidates he could make them come to
him that may be his best move in certain
ways because then he gets to be the
leader of a movement as opposed to the
guy who's expected to actually implement
and Bernie's not going to be able to
implement a damn thing I mean Bernie
doesn't have the power he doesn't have
the the support of legislators in order
to do all of this but if he just sits
outside and he talks about all of his
socialist priorities and Democrats
mirror his socialist priorities he can
actually pose more of a threat from the
outside than he does from the inside but
it is very clear that the DNC is moving
in Bernie's direction Tom Perez who took
over the DNC from Donna Brazile we
talked about down in Brazil yesterday
the reason all this is coming up is
because Donna Brazile has a new book or
she says hillary clinton took over the
democratic party wholesale in august of
2015 long before she was the nominee now
Perez runs the party and he's just
trying to keep his head down saying
we're gonna move forward when he means
by move forward is follow Bernie down
that primrose path here well hey we're
moving forward we're building you know
I've been asked that question a number
of times since I started and one of my
goals here is the DNC chair is to make
sure that the nominating process
in for 2020 is a process that's totally
fair and transparent for everybody
that's what we're fighting for that's
what we will do and we're gonna set the
the primary debate schedule well in
advance of when we know who the the
candidates will be there we have to make
sure that everything is fair and open
and everybody has a fair shake okay so
that obviously he's now paying lip
service to Bernie Sanders amid all of
this one of the points that's worth
making here is it really is fascinating
how the 2016 election played out in
light of the fact that Hillary Clinton
was picking up all of Barack Obama's
bills at the DNC one thing that Donna
Brazile said in that piece is that
Barack Obama had run up twenty four
million dollars in debt against the DNC
and then Hillary Clinton came in and
back filled that debt well maybe that
was one of the reasons why Barack Obama
kept saying to Joe Biden he wasn't going
to endorse him because this was one of
the questions during the primaries what
if Barack Obama had endorsed Joe Biden
wouldn't buy them then have beaten
Hillary Clinton in the primaries and
nobody could really understand why it
was that Joe Biden wasn't getting
Obama's endorsement Obama had talked in
warm terms about about Biden he
obviously likes Joe Biden a lot you felt
that Joe Biden was it was a good support
for him and yet he was standing aside
and letting Hillary Clinton basically
take the lead it is not unheard of for
presidents to endorse their vice
presidents during the primary cycle that
is not unheard of it all in fact it
happens relatively routinely Obama
didn't do that maybe one of the reasons
he didn't do that is because Hillary
Clinton was basically signing the checks
for all of his bills a lot of Obama
consultants were still being paid by the
DNC with Hillary cash well all of this
was going on which shows how corrupt
Obama is if that's the case Joe Biden by
the way is probably gonna run again in
2020 but now Joe Biden could run into
the Bernie Sanders buzzsaw Biden is
still making the rounds talking about
Trump tweeting and all the rest of this
Trump had a long tweet storm today about
how the DNC is corrupt and how it should
be investigated by the FBI and the DOJ
I'll talk about that in just a second
but here is Joe Biden desperately trying
to cling to relevance we gotta stop this
tweeting we gotta stop this sort of you
know
it is so I tried to stay out of the mosh
pit the president I bomb and I haven't
but it's childish it's time to grow up
pretty amazing and so Joe Biden
continues to try and maintain his place
is a possible 2020 frontrunner now I do
want to talk in just a second about why
it is that this is a problem for the
Democratic Party and why it's gonna
continue to be a problem for the
Democratic Party Plus Hillary's
corruption still looms as a specter on
the horizon and why neither party will
let it go in just a second I also want
to talk about Republicans on taxes and a
big loophole that they created that's
kind of disastrous but first I want to
say thank you to our sponsors over at
the u.s. ECA so the u.s. concealed-carry
Association makes sure that you have all
the resources necessary to protect your
family you think it's just as simple as
having a gun in your house and being
able to use it when an intruder shows up
but there's a lot that happens after you
pull the trigger the police show up they
ask you questions if you answer the
questions wrong you could end up in
prison that's why you need to talk with
my friends at the u.s. CCA
they'll give my listeners they're
complete concealed carry and family
defense guide 100% free when you contact
them
it's 164 pages of life-saving
information you can't find anywhere else
that free guide helps you understand
confusing gun laws responsibly owned
in-store gun particularly if you have
small children as I do trained for
real-life scenarios survive the waters
of the legal system get everything you
need to know from the experts in one
convenient place go to defend my family
now calm right now and begin your simple
rewarding journey to concealed carry and
home defense confidence by the way if
you hurry right now you also get the
complete audio version and bonus home
defense checklist 100% free defend my
family now calm right now for free
instant access again.this defend my
family now calm defend my family now
calm
okay so again Joe Biden vs. Bernie
Sanders it's looking like the Battle of
the of the Walker riding Titans they're
just gonna beat each other with with
walkers with tennis balls at the end of
them and then they'll run against Donald
Trump who will also be in a walker it'll
just be wildly entertaining in 2020 but
Joe Biden looks like he will get the
short end of the stick he got it from
Hillary last time now it looks like he's
gonna get it from Bernie Sanders a big
problem for the Democratic Party because
all of the splits that pre-existed are
now going to be exacerbated Bernie
Sanders is not a unifying figure Bernie
Sanders is a very divisive figure inside
the Democratic Party the Hillary wing
still thinks she got
the Hillary wind still thinks she should
be president Hillary is still out there
defending herself the best thing that
could happen for the Democratic Party is
for Hillary to just disappear this is
why there's a concerted attempt now to
do away with all of the Hillary Clinton
people right Tom Perez five minutes ago
just fired the top DNC fundraiser
claiming that basically this person was
involved in the in the hillary stuff
they aren't explicitly saying that but
that seems to be the implication because
slow fundraising has plagued the party
Bernie Sanders is the only capable
fundraiser in the party anymore along
with Nancy Pelosi that's it all right so
the Democrats are now gonna fight an
internal battle Hillary continues to
cling to her relevance to Steve got
Biden clinging to his relevance Hillary
cleaned her relevance and Bernie Sanders
ascendant pretty amazing here's Hillary
Clinton yesterday trying to explain why
she didn't collude with Russia even
though she paid millions of dollars
apparently in order to get a dossier on
Donald Trump that involved getting
information directly from Russian
governmental sources okay so she says
that she's been blaming on the FBI but
that's really not the question here the
question is why was she paying Russian
sources to obtain information on
President Trump and she's not able to
shake this the fact that she continues
to be in the public eye is a disaster
for Democrats it's a disaster it is
great for president from however because
President Trump needs Hillary Clinton to
be out there the reason he means Hillary
Clinton be out there is so long as
Hillary Clinton is out there the specter
of Hillary looms large all the folks who
voted who voted for President Trump
don't have to consider whether they
would vote for him again right because
now it's the same election over and over
and over I think you just do the same
election over and over in their heads if
you voted for Donald Trump it's not that
he has to do a good job all you have to
do is look on the TV screen there's
Hillary Clinton you breathe a sigh of
relief at least we didn't get her and
this is the way people are engaging
president Trump's performance at this
point not by whether he's doing a good
job not by whether he's been successful
now where he's been successful or how
he's been successful but at least he's
not that lady so her continued presence
on the national stage the the ubiquity
of her of her mug on the on the
television set very very good for for
President Trump and Trump jazz up his
base when he says stuff like this a
Trump told on my friend Larry O'Connor
over in Washington DC
he told Larry that he's very frustrated
he can't personally go after Hillary
Clinton the left is going nuts over this
but but you know Trump knows exactly
what he's doing when he says it saddest
thing is that because of the President
of the United States I am not supposed
to be involved with the Justice
Department
I'm not supposed to be involved with the
FBI I'm not supposed to be doing the
kind of things that I would love to be
doing and I'm very frustrated but okay
so a lot of people I'm left went nuts
over this a lot of people on the Left
suggested that this is president from
stick tutorial Sensibility coming to the
fore he wants to prosecute Hillary
Clinton let's be very real about this
this is Trump saying he can't do it
right this is from saying he can't do it
for all of his eliminations on Twitter
what Trump is doing here is certainly no
worse than what President Obama did
repeatedly with the IRS where he kept
saying that would be great if someone
would go after these 501 C 3 's these
conservative 501 C 3 s and then
administrators at the IRS got the
picture and they went ahead and went
after the conservative 501 C 3 s it's
very funny to watch the left which
seriously objects to what Trump is
saying publicly basically gloss over the
IRS scandal and pretend that it never
happened now listen I don't think that
the president should be telling the FBI
what to do it does require a certain
level of Independence he has power over
the FBI because he has power over his
DOJ but we don't want the DOJ to simply
become an arm of the White House it was
under President Obama it's not under
President Trump is something that even
the left should acknowledge okay the DOJ
under President Trump is not an arm of
the White House it really has not been
Eric Holder was the guy who described
himself as Barack Obama's wingman if you
want to talk about perversion of the DOJ
to the uses of the White House it was a
lot worse under Obama than it was under
Trump and this is coming from someone
who's very skeptical of Trump's
perspective on the Constitution and the
rule of law
okay Trump has certainly not used the
DOJ as his weapon against political
opponents in nearly the way that
Democrats use the DOJ as a weapon on
behalf of their political allies that is
clearly true talk to Jay Christian Adams
who's over at the DOJ during the Obama
administration and the DOJ Civil Rights
Division was basically throwing out
cases against the Black Panthers even as
the Black Panthers the new Black
Panthers were wielding night sticks
outside of voting places right the DOJ
under Obama was much more wing of the
White House than it is under President
Trump so I don't buy a lot of the the
kind of left-wing outrage the Trump is
trying to SiC the DOJ and the FBI on on
Hillary Clinton to do it he actually has
the power to do it but he is not doing
that right now so the left needs to just
calm down okay so in a second I want to
talk about the Republican tax plan then
we have the mailbag today that's why
it's a great time for you to subscribe
if you subscribe right now like
literally right now
a month then you can watch the rest of
the show live and be part of the mailbag
you can have your questions answered
today on our show which is awesome you
can also get the andrew Clavin show
fully live on video you can get the the
Michael Knowles show fully live on video
and the Shapiro store is coming I keep
promising it I've been doing it for two
years but unlike some other politicians
I'm not a politician that means that
this is true it is coming we have built
out things to the store the gear is
already getting ready we've already
cleared the gear so all of that is
coming and you'll get discounts if you
are a member also if you get the annual
subscription then you get all of this
for 99 bucks a year rather than $9.99 a
month you save 20 bucks also you get the
leftist tears hot or cold tumblers that
annual subscription is definitely a
bargain so check that out leftist tears
hot or cold tumbler the greatest of all
beverage vessels if we as we have stated
repeatedly please also subscribe to our
youtube channel where we have lots of
breaking video content that comes out on
a regular basis we're gonna be talking
to Adam Carolla today that's gonna be on
our YouTube channel and Facebook so
subscribe to our YouTube channel over
there and please listen later at
SoundCloud or iTunes subscribe leave us
a review we always appreciate it we are
the largest fastest growing conservative
podcast in the nation
[Music]
okay so I want to talk a little bit
about the the Republican tax plan so
yesterday I ran through some of the
things you need to know about the
Republican tax plan what I basically
said is it makes some difference for
people in the middle class it raises
taxes a little bit on people who are in
the the upper bracket and it definitely
lowers taxes on corporate on corporate
taxes the corporate tax rate reduction
from thirty five percent to twenty
percent is definitely a massive
improvement thirty five percent is the
highest corporate tax rate in the
industrialized world so that would be a
big move however the Republicans as
always failed to make their argument
they always buy into left-wing premises
and then they use those to make bad
arguments so in example today there's a
loophole in the new in the new
Republican tax bill to remember the
Republicans run the house they run the
Senate they run everything right the
Republicans run the whole shebang they
don't have to bargain with the Democrats
and yet now they are basically
primitively bargaining here is what they
did in the new house tax bill doesn't
just leave taxes in place for people who
earn more than five hundred thousand
dollars in couples earning more than a
million dollars it increases taxes by
six percent on each dollar earned from 1
million bucks
to 1.2 million bucks for single people
and 1.2 million bucks to 102 1.6 million
bucks for married couples okay so in
other words it actually raises taxes on
people who are high-income earners that
is designed to make up for the reduction
in the lowest tax bracket to 12% so low
tax bracket is moving down to 12% from
something like 25% as phil kirpan has
pointed out this means the effective
rate in the bubble is 46 percent so if I
make between a million bucks and 1.6
million bucks or between 1.2 and 1.6
million bucks I'm Mary that means that
every dollar I earn their 50% of it will
go to the federal government almost 50%
of it will go to the federal government
plus that also means that because this
tax bill basically gets rid of the state
tax deduction meaning that California
has 10 percent state income tax and then
there's a business tax in the city of
Los Angeles that means that every dollar
between that I earn between 1.2 and 1.6
million dollars that looks more like 60
percent of my income leaving my pocket
in that in that case which is an insane
amount of money that's an insane amount
of money this should be frank about this
you know the fact that that's all that I
have to make a lot of money in order to
pay the tax I'm very grateful for the
fact that I make a lot of money it's my
money
it
not the government's money it is not
your money it is my money just as when I
was making $60,000 a year that was my
money I'm the same person I'm earning
the same way that means that the money
is mine the money is not yours
Republicans failed to understand this
basic point and so they engage in class
warfare in a stupid way
they're constantly granting the point
this is the sort of idiot populism that
I keep hearing from people on the right
they grant the left's point that it is
fairer to tax people at the upper end of
the income spectrum nonsense nonsense
taking a dollar from someone's pocket
without an exchange of services is theft
okay the exchange of surfaces in in the
Constitution is roads bridges defense
right because you have the equal
capacity to use these things but not for
redistribute of programs not for Social
Security not for Medicare okay the idea
that you get to remove money from my
pocket and give me nothing in return
just because I'm earning more money than
I was five years ago seems to me morally
unprincipled I give lots of charity
that's good it's on me but the
government seizing money from people's
pockets and they can do it to me they
can do it to you and that's exactly what
they do in socialistic countries like
Denmark so Denmark has low corporate tax
rates by the way but really high
individual tax rates if they can take
sixty percent of my income between 1.2
and 1.6 milla I'm lucky enough to make
that this year then they can move that
down to tax bracket wise until they're
making up this deficit because bottom
line is both parties want to blow out
the debt here's the other thing that
Republicans fail Republicans should make
this argument okay the reality is the
money in my pocket is better for the
economy
than the money in the pocket of somebody
who is who is lower on the income
spectrum that is not a rip I'm the
person who's lower on the income
spectrum that person may need the money
more than I do I will freely admit that
but in terms of who pays that person to
have a job it is me there are a lot of
people who are at my company who are
making you know 60 grand a year 75 grand
a year there are a lot of people at this
company who are earning at the
middle-class income in the income
bracket if I'm not making as much money
if my company isn't making as much money
okay and it's being redistributed to the
people who work for me
is that supposed to be a benefit of them
because what happens if I just decide to
shut it down the case in point of this
is that Joe Ricketts who who owns the he
owns Gothamist or did and New York Asst
he just shut down the companies why
because all of the employee
decided to unionize a week later he said
screw this I'm not making enough money
on he shut it down was that good for
them was it good for the economy or
would it have been better for them not
to unionize and instead go in and ask
for raids if they thought they deserved
it well basically when the government
removes income from my pocket it's the
government unionizing my workers against
me right I mean that's basically what
it's doing it's basically them saying
your workers should get more of your
profits and therefore we are going to
take your money out of your pocket and
give it to your workers it doesn't work
that way this is why businesses shut
down you increase the rate of Taxation
high enough and businesses will shut
down again is this particular tax
increase the biggest deal do I think
that it's not worth voting for the tax
bill ever no I don't know I survive of
course I'll survive I'm not complaining
about the about the amount of taxes
breaking me or anything I don't think
that's real what I am saying is that
Republicans failed to make honest
economic arguments and they failed make
honest moral arguments taxation at root
is theft unless you're giving back
products and services in exchange for
the taxation and it is also true that
people at the upper end of the income
spectrum are the people who are creating
the vast majority of jobs in the country
and paying by the way nearly all of the
net taxes in the country the top tax
bracket paid ninety five percent of all
net income taxes in the United States
net meaning they don't get any services
back but people in the lower income
brackets do Republicans don't make these
arguments because they think it's
politically unpalatable that people
won't understand them I don't think
that's right I think people get this I
think everybody works for a rich person
right until I was rich I worked for rich
people I still work for people richer
than I am okay that's the way this works
okay the fact is that an economy runs
based on the expenditure of capital in
pursuit of better jobs and services
better goods and services and if the
people at the upper end are gonna be
punished for doing now you're gonna see
the jobs market you're gonna see the
jobs market go down the reason I hate
this is not cuz that again because I
think it's a huge deal but because when
you use Democratic arguments you're
never gonna win because what the
Democrats are gonna do is they're gonna
say listen the Republicans are right of
course we should tax the people at the
upper end more
why don't we tax them ninety percent
right is the argument the chanc Eiger
made when we debated he said well the
economy was better when we had people at
the upper income brackets people were
making more than a million dollars
paying ninety percent of their income to
the federal government
first of all important to note virtually
everyone avoided taxes right the
effective tax rate for people making
more than a million dollars in those
years was incredibly low because
everybody was just using every loophole
available so that tax
was never achieved but beyond that the
Democrats can use this argument for
anything once you acknowledge that
people who earn more should pay more
taxes not as not as an absolute amount
which is fine but on a percentage basis
once you say that you're basically
acknowledging that you get to rob Peter
to pay Paul and eventually Peter gets
sick of being robbed and he's gonna stop
hiring people so the you know again the
GOP needs to get out of this rut where
they continue to to nonsensically mirror
the things the Democrats say about tax
policy okay time for some things I like
and then some things I hate and then
we'll get to the mailbag so things I
like this week I've been doing books
about children and books about parenting
Amy Chua has a really fun book called
Battle Hymn of the tiger mother it made
a lot of noise at the time Amy Chua is a
professor I believe at Yale and and her
book is basically about raising her
children in a sort of traditional
Chinese way meaning achievement -
oriented that self-esteem is not given
it is earned and I think that there's a
lot to this I mean if you want to look
at areas of the world where children are
the best educated areas of the world
where children are high achievers
they're all areas of the world where
parents don't shy away from putting
pressure on their children to achieve
it's a world where they demonstrate high
expectations for their children we in
America have this this bizarre notion
that if we treat our children like
Rousseau treats a meal that we just let
our kids run around free naked on the
playground somewhere that they're gonna
end up being a Nobel Prize winning
scientist that's not the reality okay
the push to achieve is something that is
deeply necessary Battle Hymn of the
tiger mother is a really fascinating
memoir about her raising of her children
and how to sort of balance American
tendencies with with Chinese tendencies
as issue puts it so I check it out
Battle Hymn of the tiger mother by Amy
Chua okay well time for a couple of
things that I hate and then I would want
to spend some real time with mailbag
today
so Tucker Carlson who is an immensely
talented guy but who has done this
mirroring of the populist stick for at
least the last several years
he he decided to go off on what he calls
the ruling class now I have real
objections to this notion the
quote-unquote ruling class court of the
ruling class I mean Tucker Carlson grew
up about as Tony as a cat sir I mean
Tucker Carlson grew up in the lap of
privilege his mother I believe is
Margaret Carlson he grew up like a multi
multi-millionaire Tucker Carlson has
been earning his entire career that's
not a rip on Tucker but all of that sort
of class warfare you hear this from
Laura Ingraham to the elites okay when
you're making as much money and you went
to the best pro you went to the best
schools as Laura did and you clerked for
Justice Thomas I'm pretty sure we can
call you an elite this idea that the
ruling class prefers immigrants to
Americans here's what Tucker Carlson has
to say about this now I think that there
is something to be said for the idea
that there are folks on the left that
leftist ideology favors the importation
of people who do not buy into American
culture over people who actually buy
into American culture Tucker's about to
say here smacks to me of both class
warfare and a little bit of
anti-immigrant sentiment I'll explain
why in a second why was this man even in
our country well he was here because
this country's leaders have decided that
diversity in and of itself is of greater
importance than the well-being of this
country's people that's literally true
sigh pob was admitted to the u.s. under
the so called diversity lottery
something you've likely never even heard
of until today and then he continued
that part what he said is not so bad but
then he said that she said quote the
truth is our ruling class prefers
immigrants to Americans they don't say
that out loud they don't need to say it
out loud watch how they act were they
more worried about the so-called
dreamers here illegally or the 60,000
American citizens who died of drug
Odie's last year it's not even close
well that's not really true I mean the
amount of Ire that's been poured on the
opioid epidemic is pretty significant
but the idea that our ruling class
prefers immigrants to Americans here's
why I say this is sort of anti-immigrant
sentiment not all immigrants are the
same I have a big thing here on the
program and in my general political
philosophy everyone gets treated as an
individual the idea that all Americans
are better than all immigrants or all
immigrants are better than all Americans
is stupid just because you were born in
the United States does not mean you're a
moral human being it doesn't mean you
are of higher Worth there are lots of
immigrants I prefer to Americans
depending on the American and there are
lots of Americans why things stink
okay the lots of Americans who are
better than some immigrants and there
are some immigrants were better than
lots of Americans to pretend that all
immigrants are the same and all
Americans are the same or that you are a
higher moral value or worth because you
are an American or that we shouldn't
attempt to import people who have good
moral values is stupidity okay some of
the people who are proudest of in
American history were immigrants
obviously and some of the people who are
least proud of our immigrants saipa
we're not proud of him right immigrant
Albert Einstein kind of proud of him
immigrant okay the fact is not all
immigrants are created the same so when
he says you know they prefer immigrants
to Americans I prefer people who buy
into American ideology I preferred
people who buy into traditional
political philosophy of the United
States over everyone whether they are
immigrants or native-born that's why
I've said and I've said it before and
I'll say it again I would prefer to
deport a bunch of Americans who don't
believe in American philosophy rather
than illegal immigrants who come here
and want to engage in American
philosophy because I care about the
philosophy okay I care much more about
the philosophy I shouldn't say illegal
immigrants but immigrants themselves
okay where you came from is a little
matter to me
what you believe is a total import to me
sigh pop should not have been the in the
United States not because Sai Baba was
an immigrant but because there is no
proof that Sai pop actually believed in
American ideology when he was allowed
into the country that's why I don't like
this particular binary that the Tucker
is choosing to play on it's it's maxed
me of nativism rather than the
patriotism I think patriotism is about
upholding American principles and
nativism is about upholding the notion
that you are better if you are born in
the United States I don't like that idea
at all okay other things that I hate
April Ryan asked a question at the White
House press conference the other day
that was really one of the Dumber
questions she asked sarah huckabee
Sanders whether Donald Trump believes in
slavery whether they think slavery is
wrong then she defended that the other
day question is does this administration
believe mr. president believe slavery
was wrong and before you answer
Mary Frances very historian said in 1860
there was a compromise the compromise
was to have southern states keep slavery
but the Confederacy fired on Fort Sumter
something that caused the city and
because of the Civil War what happened I
think it is disgusting and absurd to
suggest that anyone inside of this
building would support slavery and shoes
of course exactly right but this is
something Democrats have been doing for
decades Joe Biden suggested about Mitt
Romney in 2012 and of course there's no
evidence to suggest that anyone in the
White House supports slavery and so this
is you wanna know why I got Trump again
for the one millionth time this is why
you got Trump you accused everyone who
disagrees with you everyone who
basically repeats the Ken Burns version
of the civil war narrative or the Shelby
Foote version of the Civil War narrative
you use that as an excuse to say that
they love slavery it's absurd okay time
for the mailbag so if you are in our
live if you're watching this live you
know I get to type in your questions and
I will answer them as they come up okay
so David says I am a fellow California
lawyer who just subscribed to The Daily
wire and have often wondered why are so
many extremely successful entrepreneurs
Bill Gates Oprah Winfrey Warren Buffett
George Soros the Liberal Democrats
thereby supporting a financial system
that is antithetical to their success so
I think that some of these people were
on the left before they became very
wealthy but I think another thing that
happens and you see this in Hollywood a
lot is a lot of people who get very
wealthy then feel the need to sort of
make excuses for their wealth they're
not proud of it right then they don't go
around saying you know I earned this and
I'm proud that I earned this because
that shows you know that I've done well
and made good decisions in business
instead it turns into how can I buy off
the public how can I make the public
think I'm a good guy I can't make the
public think I'm a good guy if they just
look at my wealth and say he made good
decisions instead I'm gonna suggest in
my wealth it's some sort of it's some
sort of cruel burden to be borne and
instead I'm going to handle off my
wealth right here's the fact about Bill
Gates or Warren Buffett or George Soros
or Oprah Winfrey all of these people
have created many many many many many
more jobs in their businesses than they
have in giving charity the Bill Gates
Foundation has done less for the world
than Bill Gates in his corporate
capacity and that's not a rip on the
Bill Gates Foundation doing things but I
think there is a guilt that is
associated with wealth in
Western countries that is entirely
unjust and inappropriate there are good
people who are rich and there are very
bad people who are rich Don says with
the Catalonians voting for independence
what do you think the outcome will be
you know I don't know enough about that
subject to really comment intelligibly
on it so I'm gonna read up on it and get
back to you dawn you know I do find it
sort of hysterical that the one thing
that I found sort of hilarious is that
the Catalonians are voting for
independence that for a long time
Catalonia has wanted to be independent
from Spain and and the Israelis endorsed
the Catalonian independence effort and
Spain went nuts and the Israelis
basically laughed at them and said guys
you're the ones who are pressuring us to
make concessions to Hamas so you should
up Kyle says hey Ben currently applying
for law school next fall working on my
personal statement any advice Kyle keep
politics out of it you want to get into
a good law school
do not go political because the fact is
that any excuse that some of these law
schools have and law professors have the
admissions boards have for kind of
covering over your your politics they
will they will do that Jacqueline says
dear Ben what's it your kids dress up as
for Halloween so I dressed up for
Halloween on the show because it's sort
of fun gagged but we don't actually
celebrate Halloween in the Orthodox
community typically because it's sort of
considered a pagan holiday just as in
many evangelical communities Halloween
isn't a big thing when I was growing up
and we weren't as Orthodox and I used to
dress up for Halloween but we have a
whole holiday in the Jewish community
where kids dress up
it's called poram and we do that in
March you usually it's March or April so
we'll be doing that last year my kids my
we like to do family family costumes
because that's that's really fun so last
year I went as the straw man my wife
went as Dorothy my dad went as The Tin
Man my mom went as the Wicked Witch of
the West and my two kids went as
respectively Glinda and the Cowardly
Lion so it was it was quite adorable I
have pictures of it this is one of the
great tragedies I think of the social
media age and the fact there's somebody
garbage people out there is my kids are
just adorable I mean as people in this
room can attest to be fired my kids are
incredibly cute my kids my kids are very
like objectively speaking they're
beautiful children and they also happen
to be really sweet and I wish I could
put up pictures of them because would
probably double my social media
following but it's no it's nobody's
business what my kids look like and my
kids shouldn't be saddled with the
burden of having a public figure for a
dad so I try to keep them out of the
public eye as much as possible Matthew
Ben I usually try to ask questions that
have either cultural or political
significance but those never get read
during the podcast so in hopes of
getting my question read live I have to
ask boxers or briefs so I always
hesitate to answer these particular
questions but in all kanzen aside go
with boxer briefs I go with boxer briefs
from our from our particular friends
over over at the company that we endorse
so it is they are terrific by the way so
if you don't know a company that is just
look up on our website and Todd says
have you seen Stephen Crowder's
impersonation of you it's pretty good
I'm curious can you impersonate steven
crowder I've never actually tried or
thought about impersonating Crowder
first I'd have to put on a t-shirt or
take off my shirt entirely second I'd
have to really bulk up like just guzzle
steroids and and and wait powders and
all this sort of thing and then I'd have
to dance
geek elite ooh bad music so that would
be the way that I would imitate steven
crowder you know lots of lots of head
motions I would imagine but I haven't
spent too much time on it and naftali
says hey Ben what are your thoughts on
the draft do you think it is beneficial
in countries that have mandatory service
would it benefit the u.s. if we
reinstituted it is it legal I am Not
sure that well the draft is legal in
emergency situations I am NOT a huge fan
of reinstituting the draft I think that
Israel has national service I think that
a lot of the public education that is
that is done is it like well it's
mandatory that we go to schools I think
that we have a failure of schools not a
failure of public service so the idea
that we have to take two years of
everybody's life and dedicate it to the
state not a big fan of if you don't have
an emergency situation if you do have an
emergency situation I'm in favor of a
giraffe right if it's World War two and
you need to call people up then you call
people up but the idea that everyone has
to serve the nation in some way it's not
something I'm a huge fan of I think we
just need to do better civil education
Eric says hey Ben I will preface this
with me being an atheist I want to learn
more about Judaism in Christianity as
presented by their respective churches
do synagogues allow atheists to sit and
listen yeah I mean if you show up at a
synagogue nobody's gonna toss you out
nobody's gonna say like do you believe
in God and if you say no then we just we
hit you with it with a Star of David
that's that's that's not how it works so
you're welcome to show up at a synagogue
you know I'd recommend that that's
actually not the best way to learn about
church or synagogue is to show up at
their services because services can be
extremely boring
I would instead recommend that there are
some classes you can take online and
then you also don't make everybody
awkward when you show up wearing your
your cutoff jeans in the middle of an
Orthodox prayer service which just makes
everyone feel weird okay Brendan says
what is my favorite pudding cup flavor
so I will acknowledge that's my
favourite pudding cup flavor is vanilla
I truly enjoy vanilla it is delicious
also when you mix the vanilla and the
chocolate it is also delicious candy
says is putting kosher it depends on the
brand of pudding Daniel says how long do
you think Bernie could survive without
pudding well you know we haven't tried
it you know I'm not sure how long Bernie
could survive without pudding
I wouldn't want to try it but Bernie
should live long masane blessing I have
for this are May he made me hit may he
live well and live far far away from me
like that so that's that's my basic
Bernie Sanders thing and I hope that he
survives many years on pudding cups
okay Ryan says I've recently started
listening your podcast I'm very
impressed you seems to accomplish a
great deal I was wondering how you
managed to do so much do you sleep yeah
actually I sleep pretty well um I tried
to pack in all of my work in specific
hours of the day and really focus when
I'm working so Twitter does not help
with this but it seems to me that most
of the time that's lost during the day
is lost to being distracted you're in
the middle of a task and then you look
up and ten minutes have gone by and you
haven't done anything when I'm writing
I'm writing when I'm reading I'm writing
when I'm on Twitter I'm on Twitter my
Nate says watching the new Star Wars
trailers and reading some about the new
can and it seems like Disney is setting
up a breakdown of the difference between
the light and dark sides of the force
that it is all just the force do you
think this is likely and do you think
this is an intentional step in
forwarding a moral relativist agenda I
don't think that it's an intentional
step in forwarding a moral relativist
agenda I just think that if you read
some of the Star Wars literature there
have been hints at this I also think
that basically at a certain point people
are bored of the dark side of the force
versus the light side of the force and
they're trying to come up with something
new and the two things that they have
come up with that are new or maybe the
crossover between the light and dark
sides of the force and app org those are
those are the two things that they have
come up with in her new eye I will say
that I'm interested in the in the merger
of the light that are excited the force
because I've always thought that this
sort of Zen view of quote unquote the
force was kind of dumb
this idea that this is this binary
almost Gnostic view of the force that
you know you fall into the evil side of
the porch and it's powered by anger and
fear I really don't like that because
sometimes anger is justified like it
seems to me that Luke has some pretty
good excuse to be pissed at the end of
Return of the Jedi and then they're like
well you're going to fall to the dark
side if you ever get mad never get mad
it seems to me there's some good times
to get mad like when when when the
Emperor is threatening to kill your
sister you know that seems to me like a
pretty good time to get mad when he's
like laughing as you're dazz your
friends are getting blown up in space it
seems like a good time to get pissed and
by the way one thing I've always found
weird about Return of the Jedi
is that is that his anger obviously does
make him stronger right he literally
beats Darth Vader down and then chops
off his hand and then he steps back and
he turns off the lightsaber and like
he's very lucky that Darth Vader decides
to turn around and be hit be a nice dad
and all but if Darth Vader decides to
get up and kill him this does not go
well for him like how many times can
obi-wan Kenobi die before you just end
up with like in afterlife full of Jedi
who are who are glowing I can't actually
do anything useful okay Jackson says how
do we encourage businesses to take
advantage of free markets while also
discouraging monopolies well I don't
think you have to encourage businesses
to take advantage of free markets the
only thing you have to do is discourage
monopolies and the way monopolies are
generally established is through
government it's through people working
with the government and getting the
government to ban competition and
prevent competition so if you can if you
can get the government out of the
business of markets then monopolies very
rarely occur and many times monopolies
aren't quite good for the market I mean
Microsoft one was broken up had cheaper
prices than after it was broken up is
good for consumers the way that you
maintain a monopoly is by creating a
great product that you continually
change see Tyra says what issues you
believe the libertarian solution is
better than the conservative one other
than drugs so it depends on the drugs
have said I think marijuana it's a
better solution libertarian solutions on
marriage I think are right I've said
that I think the states you get
completely out of the business of
marriage
yeah I'm struggling to come up with
examples where conservatism and
libertarianism erratically differ on
matters of economics usually they're
pretty much on the same page
I think the libertarian solution with
regard to incentivization of behavior is
generally better I don't think the
government is good as and incentivizing
behavior
as if it says my son who's otherwise
rational insane has fallen for the Flat
Earth conspiracy and believes that NASA
and every other space program is lying
and everything is faked
he's also shouldn't prevent propensity
to want to believe in other conspiracy
theories how would you recommend helping
him recognize the problem with
conspiracy theories and develop strong
or critical thinking skills well I think
the first thing that you should do you
know first of all I mean I hesitate to
say this on you know national air but I
will say that if your kid is
continuously falling for conspiracy
theories you should probably get your
kid to a psychologist really because
that tends to be a little bit
pathological like if you believe in lots
of conspiracy theories and people are
out to get you and everybody's lying to
you there tends to be a certain
pathology to that that I don't think is
healthy
beyond that if it's just a matter of
critical thinking then maybe you should
ask him why he believes that people are
so capable of putting together these
plans they in his own personal
experience are people really good at
putting things together like here's my
general problem with conspiracy theories
it requires thousands of people to be in
on it
right conspiracy theories that involved
with one guy I'm generally okay with
right like the Obama incentivizing the
IRS to go after the the conservative
seal and 501c3
it makes perfect sense to Obama saying
things and people taking him up on it
that doesn't require a whole hell of a
lot but the idea that George W Bush was
behind the 9/11 attacks for example
idiotic right because you know how many
people would have to be in on that and
keep silent about it the biggest scandal
in the history of the world and this
idea that there was some sort of giant
conspiracy to cover up Barack Obama's
birth certificate you know many people
would have to be in on that without it
leaking a lot of people so I just don't
believe that people are that capable and
you should ask your son whether he
believes people are that capable because
I don't think that that is perfectly
accurate okay so we have come to the end
of this week's mailbag I have to say I'm
disappointed in some of the live
questioners who seem to only be
interested in pudding but apparently you
guys were only interested in pudding to
which I suggest you go out buy some
pudding satisfy your craving and come
back with better questions next week in
the meantime have a good weekend we'll
see you on Monday
I'm Ben Shapiro this is the Ben Shapiro
show
[Music]